Disney has produced dozens of animated
classics over the years all of them
packed with memorable images there are
some images though that we just have to
linger on longer than others here are
some of the most memorable Disney movie
moments that will make you say did I see
what I thought I saw pick up the remote
and hit pause released in 2003 Finding
Nemo follows the story of a little
clownfish who is separated from his
father and desperately tries to get back
home this Disney Pixar classic was a
massive hit at the box office and became
an instant success on home video clearly
it was seen by lots and lots of people
many of them more than once just keep
swimming just keep swimming just keep
swimming swimming swimming that said it
wasn't until many years after finding
Nemo's release that many viewers noticed
one key detail during Nemo's journey he
ends up in the fish tank at a dentist's
office when he wakes up in the tank the
camera pans around the dentist's waiting
room showing what Nemo can see from his
watery vantage point the view shows some
toys lying on the floor and one of them
happens to be a familiar face its Buzz
Lightyear who made his first movie
appearance in Pixar's Toy Story 8 years
earlier Pixar is fond of leaving Easter
eggs for its viewers to find and since
this one involves two of the most
popular and heartwarming Disney films
ever made
it's exciting to pause the movie long
enough to spot Buzz Lightyear's cameo
originally released in 1996 The
Hunchback of Notre Dom follows the story
of Quasimodo a man who has rejected by
his people because of his deformity
Quasimodo lives in a tower in Notre
Dom's Cathedral in Paris where he serves
as the bellringer and spends his days in
solitude wishing for someone to share
his life with at the beginning of the
movie Quasimodo sings the song out there
from the top of note Redang Cathedral
the camera pans along the street below
and as it moves we can see a man shaking
out a piece of fabric look closely and
you'll see it's the magic flying carpet
that Disney fans will recognize from
Aladdin if that isn't enough to make you
pause here are two bonuses if you look
closely enough you'll also see Belle
from Beauty and the Beast
walking by with a book Aladdin is a
charming 1992 Disney movie that follows
a street urchin who discovers a genie
and a lamp and has his wishes fulfilled
but things aren't always as they seem
and Aladdin must fight an evil sorcerer
to save his love interest Princess
Jasmine Aladdin was released shortly
after another Disney classic from the
same era Beauty and the Beast both films
were extremely successful though Beauty
and the Beast might be considered the
greater classic now still the two movies
are connected by more than the calendar
in one scene in Aladdin we see Jasmine's
father the Sultan playing with a stack
of toys look closely and you'll see that
one of these toys is actually a model of
the beast from Beauty and the Beast
oscar-winning 1989 Disney classic The
Little Mermaid has one scene that's
chock-full of cameos from characters
seen in the studio's of the movies there
are so many in fact that you'll
definitely want to hit pause and count
during the scene featuring King Triton's
entrance for other Disney characters are
visible Mickey Mouse Goofy and Donald
Duck can be seen near the bottom left of
the screen it's a quick cameo though
since King Triton is moving so quickly
if you really want to spot the
characters you'll have to quickly pause
and take a close look future Disney
acquisition Kermit the Frog is there too
you can even spot the Warner Brothers
character mister limpets in The Little
Mermaid
he pops up near the end of the classic
musical number under the sea a bit of a
lesser-known character he was played by
Don Knotts who starred in the 1964
live-action/animated hybrid the
incredible mr. limpet about a man who
has turned into a fish clearly there was
plenty of room under the sea for the
animators of the Little Mermaid to show
some love to as many characters as they
wanted from Disney and Beyond the
animated Disney film 101 Dalmatians was
first released in 1961 and remains a
beloved classic it's the story of an
unlikely and truly massive family of
dogs that find themselves the target of
an evil / loving woman named Cruella De
Vil because of the adorable heroes in
the film and karelis play says one of
Disney's best loved villains fans keep
coming back to one
one Dalmatians but it turns out the dogs
of the title are far from the only
Disney pups present in the film a third
of the way through the film dogs all
across London are participating in the
Twilight bark barking to each other
across the city to spread the word that
the Dalmatians need help in this scene
we can see Jack Bull peg Lady and the
[ __ ] all characters from Disney's 1955
film lady in the [ __ ] jock recognizable
by his collar comes out of the doghouse
bull and peg who were in lady in the
[ __ ] as dogs in the pound are sitting
in the window of the pet store and
finally after a car goes by the [ __ ]
stands on top of a truck and lady is on
the street Moana is a popular 2016
animated musical about a Polynesian
teenager who embarks on a journey to
save her people and find herself it's
also packed with Easter eggs including
one that incorporated a frozen character
as Moana starts on her journey she
enlists the help of Maui a demigod who
once owned a magical hook the hook
allows Maui to transform into any animal
he wants during the middle of the movie
Maui recovers his hook and uses it to
swiftly transform from animal to animal
the transformation goes so fast that
it's a blink and misset type of scene if
you're really paying attention though
you'll see that one of the animals Maui
transforms into is spend the lovable
reindeer from frozen the scene is fast
and definitely requires a pause button
to catch the reindeer but the expression
on his face is hilarious and worth going
back for a second look the movie big
hero 6 which hit theaters in 2014 is a
superhero story about a robotics genius
who lives in a futuristic city the boy
Hiro Hamada puts together a team of
superheroes in his attempt to catch a
mysterious masked villain in one scene
Hiro goes to the San fransokyo police
station to file a report
eagle-eyed viewers will notice a wanted
poster hanging on the wall that features
none other than Prince Hans the villain
from Disney's 2013 hit frozen this cameo
was fairly easy to spot since the police
station scene was featured in the movies
trailer but Hans isn't the only frozen
character in big hero 6 others found
their way into the film - and places
that were a little bit harder to spot
a ship from arendelle the name of the
kingdom in frozen and a shot of beloved
snowman Olaf also make it into the movie
just keep hitting pause until you catch
them all
the 2001 Pixar hit Monsters Inc tells
the tale of the biggest scare Factory in
the monster world
a little girl who visits from the human
world and what happens next
oh and along the way Bello picks our
favorite Nemo makes a cameo - at one
point in the movie we can see him
hanging on the wall in a bedroom as
Sully and Mike tried to get rid of the
villainous Randall later boo and hero
monster Sully are in her room together
and she shows him a few of her favorite
toys including a stuffed Nemo here's the
real kicker though when Monsters Inc was
released Finding Nemo wasn't out yet at
the time Monsters Inc came out audiences
probably didn't think anything about the
little clownfish that popped up once or
twice many years later though diehard
fans of Finding Nemo are fumbling for
the remotes - hit that pause button and
smile at the sight of their favorite
fish tangled is a 2010 movie telling the
classic story of Rapunzel with a few
fresh twists Rapunzel is still the girl
who lives locked away in a tower with
her long flowing hair that can be used
as a rope but she's also got big dreams
Rapunzel wants to get away from the
tower and when a dashing bandit named
Flynn shows up at her window one day she
sees her chance to begin a new life it's
the start of an unlikely journey it's
packed with Disney adventure there's
something else in the film that's
unlikely - at the beginning of the movie
and Rapunzel's tower one shot shows a
spinning wheel behind the princess it's
the same spinning wheel from Sleeping
Beauty the classic 1959 Disney movie if
you haven't caught this one before
though don't feel bad even diehard
Disney fans have had to watch the movie
quite a few times to realize it's the
same spinning wheel Rapunzel's tower has
items that relate to other Disney
Princess movies - use the pause button
to look around and you'll find Snow
White's Apple Ariel's
seashell Belle's Rose and Cinderella's
slipper Wally is a 2008 movie about a
lonely little robot left behind on earth
to collect junk after the human race
abandons the ruined planet in search of
a new home at the beginning of the movie
as viewers are being introduced to Wally
and his
like the robot comes home after work and
the camera shows several items he's
collected if you look closely you might
see a familiar face peeking out from
behind a couple of bowling pins its Rex
the lovable and anxious dinosaur from
the 1995 hit Toy Story and its sequels
the rejection the scene is honestly a
little sad after all wall-e is the last
robot left on earth the planet is a
pretty empty lonely place the Rex just
get thrown away to die alone it seems
like an injustice to the poor dinosaur
but at least he has wall-e as they say
one man's trash is another robots
treasure Pocahontas released in 1995
tells the loosely fact-based story of
Native American princess Pocahontas and
English settler Captain John Smith when
the two fall in love Pocahontas is
father the chief of her tribe doesn't
approve to further complicate matters
the other settlers who arrived with
Smith are plotting to steal gold from
the Native Americans at the beginning of
the movie there is a scene during which
Pocahontas leaps off a cliff in a
majestic swan dive entering the water
with only a small splash although not
entirely realistic her swan dive is
beautiful as a kid it's fun to hit the
pause button and see if you can catch
Pocahontas right in the middle of her
leap just don't try to recreate this
scene at home Disney's Cinderella came
out in 1950 and has been delighting
audiences of all ages ever since the
tale of a girl trying to escape her
stepmothers cruelty and then attending
the royal ball with Prince Charming is a
classic but Cinderella has a second
claim to fame to the castle featured in
the movie is the same castle that forms
the basis for Walt Disney Pictures logo
what started as a simple graphic of
white lines has since become a beautiful
three-dimensional rendering at the
beginning of every Disney film you can
also visit the castle anytime you want
at Walt Disney World where it serves as
the centerpiece of the Magic Kingdom
next time you watch Cinderella it's
worth hitting the pause button during
the scene where we first see the castle
to see how familiar it seems check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you